how important has riding been to your
career as a director writing writing
well I've always admired writers as
strong as Sydney was a long time ago
said you're good writer got a great
writer but in filming in a film I like
to structure the layout the story to
structure the story there's no such
writings very ambivalent term in in
films because there's the dialogue and
there's the pictures so I might end the
structure I think the most important
thing in the film is to get the
structure run so that it starts your
I've ever built some get something and
you to the exposition and get deeper
into it and then the dry my bills and
you get a client accident it should
gallop towards the end I mean to me that
and laying up playing up the structure
film so that generates that energy and
one picture leads inexorably to the next
picture which reasoning extra blades up
next picture that's what really provides
us a pace that we were talking about
earlier and so I that to me is I try to
lay out the picture as much as possible
what i want what i wanted to do
pictorially and then with with the right
of course not we work together but the
dialogue i'm not i like fresh dialogue
and i like I'm my dialogue is not the
freshest and I like to get a good writer
who write me fresh style like an
interesting dialogue and somehow
compliments again complement what the
pictures are doing but not but not
reinforcing them and how much room was
you leave for improv in your pictures
well I think that's that's a very
difficult question of I think there are
situations when you do when I let the
actress I like working with actress I
like actors like working with them I
studied acting not not to be an actor
but to to know what the process was and
try if I can contribute in it and assist
the actor and giving the best possible
performance that he can give and
sometimes you know you put the
terrific actors when they're put in a
certain situation they come out with the
most amazing revelations about what
about the situation about themselves in
that situation and but some and so of
course you use it but then some actors
are incapable of it and really would
like to stick stick with the material
they're given but of course it is an
important part to play like anything
else I mean as much as I plan for
example my shooting I know exactly when
mi cumin in the morning you stand there
you stand bibbidi-bobbidi-boo and then
and then I said wait wait wait wait it
no no no we just do the senior and I see
something in the saintly it was you
onion two gentlemen sharing that it is
totally unexpected what happened this
white man in this black man meet for the
first time and what they and one of they
said the things in the script but I saw
something I've never seen before some
new a new energy had been generated a
new feeling and I said no no this is the
stadiums and work at all and so I i
improvised that a mer- but of course you
have to respond to what they're giving
what the actors are giving and what the
situation is getting a video so yes
improvisation can be both not just on
the dialogue but in terms of I improv
sometimes I improvised the whole staging
you